forty-five years that's almost half a
century and in that time labour MEP s
have been working with our sister
parties across Europe to end
discrimination to fight for the poorest
regions in Europe to protect rights at
work and to work for peace and unity
across our continent we have made the EU
more democratic and accountable 20 years
ago this Parliament had almost no powers
over EU policies now MEP s approval is
needed to adopt EU legislation to ratify
international agreements to appoint the
Commission and much more this in turn
has given MEP s the power to shape
policies we may be leaving for a while
but we are proud to have helped build an
EU that secures peace in Europe and
helps us achieve so much more together
than we could possibly do separately
[Music]
we've been here for 45 years making
crucial contributions every step of the
way we made sure the EU single market
has rules to protect workers consumers
the environment and we made sure the EU
is much more than just a market a social
Europe making law on energy poverty
security climate change and development
always with people at the centre it was
always about making people's lives
better
it was always about that
in the 80s labour MEP s led the drive to
increase regional funding to support
local communities for many that support
and investment is still there this has
made the EU more relevant to people and
helped counter some of the worst impacts
of cuts as labour MEP s we worked very
hard to put the social agenda front and
center of the group that meant working
very hard on workers rights employment
rights but it also meant trying to bring
our labor values to the group on big
issues like migration and security those
kind of issues that have been challenges
that dominated our lives in the past few
years there is so much more to the EU
than just treaties and euros for the
labor movement the EU is about putting
people first putting people first and
protect in the air that we breathe the
water that we drink and tackling climate
change whether it was the fall of the
Berlin Wall
Human Rights EU enlargement or the
Northern Ireland peace process this is
about people people first meant working
together with our Social Democratic
partners labour MEP s worked with our
European sister parties with all the
passion you would expect and then in
2016 there was a vote and that vote felt
like everything changed I think I was
completely stunned and shocked and then
that feeling developed into feeling
totally devastated my overriding
feelings were about my daughter and my
children's future and about what that
vote would mean for all the young people
in the next generation in my country but
for a lot of people Briggs is a very
personal thing and my first reaction to
the outcome of the referendum was to
worry about the future of my son who was
an engineer and who lives and works in
Germany I was very sad for all the young
people my family is a Belgian British
family my husband's Belgian
I have always been Pro European and the
granddaughter of a Holocaust survivor
who believed fundamentally in the
principle of Europe working together to
avoid war everything we worked so hard
to achieve was now at risk
[Music]
the fight for social justice for the
environment for peace and progress and
fairness these are shared challenges
that still need our shared values
it's not about national dividing lines
but it's about standing up for what we
believe in the challenges that we're
going to face in the future will be even
greater than those we faced to date the
changes in the economy will produce even
greater inequality left to the markets
own devices so working across borders
for a just transition and a fair outcome
for ordinary people
is it still absolutely vital we'll still
be fighting for the values that we've
been standing together on for the last
half a century we'll still be part of
the progressive family and we always
will be
[Music]
you